bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur ce sentier logos alors aujourd'hui
je vous retrouve accompagnée d'une de
mes amies donc lucy lucy qui ne mettrait
jamais on habite ensemble à istanbul en
ce moment ont fini ensemble a multiplié
ses bons amis ici azéma que vous
connaissez peut-être de twitter elle est
là en direct au chalet des journalistes
et autres is finished voyageuse tout ça
tout ça et va bientôt sortir un livre un
temps est ce qu'on a le droit de savoir
le thème ou pas oui c'est un peu le
thème de la vidéo d'aujourd'hui
on sait tous qu'on peut te voilà donc je
vais bien les infos le c sur son coup de
coeur du coup alors aujourd'hui on vous
retrouve dupoux pour parler d'un sujet
qui est un ogre en point commun c'est ça
qui est donc je te laisse annoncé le
voyage en tant que femme seule
vous êtes mauvais pourquoi on parle de
ça tout simplement cette chaîne si vous
voulez les femmes voyageuses sont des
êtres sociologique il ya des individus
sociologique très intéressant puisque
c'est un être de transgression des
normes sociales établies qui vont donc
s'affranchir du foyer de l'emprise d'un
père d'un mari et c est à travers
l'histoire il ya eu beaucoup de femmes
voyageuses
mais au final qui ont été complètement
invisible isaikin tech jeté aux
oubliettes et où quand à exister c'était
des elle était très sexualisée outre est
comme des êtres bizarres anormal
différente des autres femmes en fête
dre que par exemple la si vous
réfléchissez deux secondes est ce que
vous connaissez des grandes aventurières
généralement les gens connaissent
alexandra david néel ou non la guérilla
mais c'est est en moi c'est pas la
majorité mais plus c'est pas la majorité
personnellement j'ai appris l'existence
qui sont à blâmer mais à cause de
l'arrêt de tram à paris ah oui je savais
dans le 20e et voilà je la connaissais
pas avant ce à quoi donc
comme quoi la représentation est
probable partant exact mais c'est vrai
que la voyageuse
c'est pas une vidéo ça va marquer tout
ça allait beaucoup moins connue quand
même alors qu'elle est contre roanne
c'est ça elle est beaucoup moins connu
que des gens comme si je m'étais sont
exactement le temps qu'ils sont publiés
qui sont reconnus en tant que voyageur
présente les anthologies de voyage je
suis n'a que des hommes qui sont
présentés ne serait que dans les livres
d'histoire même tous les grands
aventuriers même de fiction indiana
jones & company bas ça qu'il ya sur la
figure viril masculine ou alors
hypersexualisée à la lara croft un peu
j'avais pas vraiment donc une voyageuse
a donc bref tout ça pour vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui on s'est dit que ça peut
être intéressant ce que toutes les deux
ont fait partie de ces femmes qui
voyagent et on a toutes les deux en plus
voyager tout seul et on a commencé sa à
ces jeunes comme un homme plus gros
point commun géré ce que c'est pas non
plus fréquent de rencontrer des mavs qui
voyage tout seul et tout est en fait ce
qui est marrant c'est que comme tous les
deux on a voyagé on se retrouve sur
plein de points etc
mais en fait on sait jamais raconter nos
voyages ouais c'est pour ça qu'on vous a
proposé de poser des questions pour
qu'on vous raconte un peu nos anecdotes
et puis à doser nos expériences ou
simplement de ceux qui ont voyagé seul
dupont à prendre là vos questions et y
répondre alors avant ces entités
alors la première question quel était
votre premier voyage solo c'était quoi
ta moi c'était en egypte
à 19 ans à thé party toi t'es tu as fait
genre pour les voyages mais j'étais
juste aller au maroc avec ma mère quand
j'avais 17 ans en tout cas j'avais
jamais ne serait-ce que prix lannion
tout seul ce qui est déjà en fête et non
c'est ça et toi c'est pas moi c'était à
nice j'avais 18 ans j'étais aussi assez
jeune et je suis parti au canada et en
en vacances à un peu particulier ce que
j'avais une bourse de voyage c'est les
bourses zellidja ça existe encore
si ça vous intéresse ou fort entre 16 et
20 ans et c'était bourse pour un peu
donné
un petit peu d'argent à des jeunes pour
qu'ils partent tous seuls c'est vraiment
le beach de la bourse on part tout seul
avec un sujet d'étude
un peu comme un reportage bon si j'étais
sur le lien sport immigration au canada
répondu à l'appel tu as de la bourse que
j'avais vu dans les couloirs de mon
lycée et en fait j'ai été prise et si on
avait quand même une somme d'argent
enfin quand tu es jeune
et puis on est là tu dis mais en fait je
suis obligé quoi je ne sais pas la mère
est sérieuse on en fait à lima dit je
pense que j'aurai ma fais moi-même quand
même ça va un peu forcé et j'ai pleuré
toutes les larmes de mon corps dans
l'avion et tout est vrai c'est stressant
toi tu étais dans quel état quand on
perd son jeu c'est tellement je crois
qu'en fait en fait j'étais un peu
inconsciente je pense donc j'étais pas
stressé ouais ouais moi j'avais un peu
fait le choix de la sécurité je m'étais
dit le canada alors je parlait pas très
bien anglais est clairement mais voyez
un truc rassurant 2-0 canada anglophone
du coup en fait j'ai traversé le canada
a oui oui j'ai atterri à montréal et je
suis allée de montréal jusqu'à vancouver
en bus les msp direz vous c'était très
long mais c'était génial parce que j'ai
vu des paysages de foucauld clairement
le centre du canada c'est extraordinaire
c'est monotone
après c'est vrai que les voyages l'an en
bus ou en train c'est vrai que c'est
c'est là aussi que tu vois le paysage
ouais tu te rends plus compte de la
distance des paysages qui changent du
climat et toi par le sait quand tu as
vraiment un départ sur le mental joue
avec eux
reste que despatie combien de temps en
egypte à un mois un mois ouais ouais
ouais je partie de moi au canada que
c'est là que j'ai attrapé a changé c'est
génial alors deuxième question à quel
âge avez-vous voyage est sous l'eau ma
première fois vous l'a dit moi j'avais
18 ans disons le clairement on est en
mode on est majeur on se bat et
franchement si les six jeunes n'ayez pas
peur
un faux pas dire ouais d'attendre et ce
que je pense a way après les jamais trop
tard ces urnes et je pense qu'on est
jamais trop jeunes dont des majeures
alors question suivante qu'est ce que
votre entourage a pensé de votre
décision
ah la la
alors là pas du voyage touristique ou
comme ça juste en back pack et tout ça
allait mais ce qui est vraiment ce qui a
vraiment posé problème pour moi c'est
quand j'ai voulu vraiment mettre toute
ma vie d'un voyage que j'ai commencé
vraiment l'art vouloir faire votre devis
on voit la loire changer de pays tout le
temps changer de boulot tout le temps un
vouloir écrire là dessus ça a été hyper
dur à accepter parce que c'est une vie
très précaires pendant de nombreuses
années alors que moi quand j'ai annoncé
mais que j'avais eu la boucle c'est que
c'était déjà c'était super fier par
contre alors là où je trouve comme ça on
sait que je pense qu'ils ont été hyper
stressée vraiment genre tu as ta fille
de 18 ans qui sont là tout c'est le ba
ba oui là c'est hyper 6 mai et il a
essayé deux pas du tout me transmettre
du coup la question suivante est ce que
vous ne voyagez que tout seul a alors
disons je pense que toutes les deux
majoritairement en vrai j'ai tout ça
enfin ouais moi j'ai fait l'idiot quand
même j'ai voyagé avec unibail sophie
ouais moi j'ai voyagé en couple c'est
vraiment parce que j'ai préféré je pense
que tu peux et adoré voyager tout seul
mais aussi mes voyages avec des gens
enfin je pense qu'en face le plus c'est
plus compliqué quand est tout le temps à
voyager avec d'autres gens et à jamais
la scène ce que tu deviens hyper
dépendant des bon vouloir des uns des
autres
des gens qui voyagent en groupe toi et
vraiment c'est là qu'on apprend en fait
quand on est tout seul on apprend
vraiment à connaître une ville en fête
et il ya les endroits moi j'ai voyagé je
me rappelle de rien parce que j'étais
avec des gens que et au final on était
dans des histoires dans des
conversations alors que quand tu es tout
seul dans une ville en fête est obligé
emmené de vraiment réfléchir comment
elle fait la ville quelles sont les
habitudes des gens qu'elles sont essayé
de comprendre ce qui se passe est
vraiment celle là en fait que tu tu
profites en trois ans gars c'est là
aussi toujours en vie d'autres gens quoi
c'est ça alors la question d'afrique
c'est quoi le plus gros clichés sur les
femmes voyageuses
alors attendez
est ce qu'il ya un peu on commence ouais
c'est ça ce qui me vient en premier
moi c'est le truc de la fille qui couche
avec tout le monde ouais ça c'est
vraiment c'est je m'y attendais pas du
tout soit ça ou soit le côté petite
chose fragile
en fait ouais c'est qu'à pas de juste
milieu en fait c'est soit tu es un
bibelot fragile au passage à mettre les
ces gens quand ils voient que le monde
mais était tout seul tu as quel âge et
oublie tout ce qu'ils veulent aider
alors ça peut être sympa mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya toujours cette volonté de
surprotéger aussi le gros clichés sur
les femmes qui voyagent c'est le côté
courageuse away genre moi c'est un
cliché de toutes les femmes voyageuses
son courage ça juste parce qu'en fait tu
lot de passe d'être seul dans l'espace
public et de dépendre de personne en
fait je dévore les livres de voyage
féminin ont écrits par des femmes jeu je
les dévore justement parce qu'il y en a
qui ont des destins vraiment hors normes
et c'est incroyable de lire ça mais la
plupart des voyagistes d'un voyage aux
lambda il y en a beaucoup
elles sont injustes elles sont aussi au
moins aussi courageuse que l'on a eu en
fait on a aussi ça on a juste eu le
courage de faire le premier pas de
partir en voyage ça veut pas dire qu'on
se sent invincible qu'on a des surfaces
ouais je pense que le courage en fait
c'est par rapport justement aux
injonctions sociale et aux clichés de la
société que ça va te renvoyer c'est
plutôt ça en fait moi ça m'a demandé
beaucoup plus de courage et d'énergie de
devoir dire bah non en fait j'ai jamais
de gros problèmes à l'étranger en tant
que femme c'est clair dans mafia
laballery en fait jamais ça c'est vrai
que c'est un énorme cliché de penser que
parce qu'on en est parti en voyage et où
on a vécu des trucs horribles a posé ses
d'écoivres pires frayeurs
vous avez pas eu trop peur tout dans le
vocal ya la peur et tu sais ça c'est que
mais parce que c'est le cliché namor
ouais ouais je voyage seule c'est
vraiment genre mais ta faveur de serre
violées fin vraiment c'est alors qu'en
fait juste on vit notre vie mais dans un
autre pays en touriste quoi on n'a pas
oublié par le soit gelée que quand on a
un seul ne soit pas si ça c'est clair et
je dirais même que c'est souvent
l'inversé
en fait les plus en conscience de ce que
tu fais des choix que tu me prends des
décisions que tu prends des choix que tu
fais et ses ventes à l'étranger
parce que justement terme le plus alerte
ouverte aux signaux extérieurs
complètement alors que c'est vrai que
dans ta propre culture dans ton pays tu
as tendance à un peu plus à moi de
laisser impressionner
dépassé par une situation enfin genre
penser mais ouais et puis c'est une
question de socialisation en fait sans
vraiment les filles et fils quand on est
plus jeune on est sociabilisés par
l'apport enfin en sociologie c'est un
concept super l'utiliser non doit
commencer en crème et même nous ont même
encore maintenant fin avait bien sûr je
pense que c'est ce qu' on ne peut pas
s'en défaire
habituellement on a été éduqué pendant
des années avec tout ce cet appareil à
la fois dans l'éducation et de la
famille de l'école des médias à avoir
peur à se dire que les ce que la rue
n'est pas à nous que ce n'est en danger
dès qu'on sort de notre maison et c est
en fait elle est d'une certaine manière
elle n'est pas vraiment à nous mais en
fait il faut justement serez à maurice
et sa sortie ok je suis l'un en fait
l'incident c'est un cercle vicieux en
arrière sur son art est de voyager
étouffe et le voyage le fait de sortir
et non pas dans sa rue mais dans le
monde
là un acte tellement radical qu'en fait
ça tu as franchi d'un coût de toutes ces
pressions là parce que tu es plus dans
l'antre de la tave déjà pris la décision
était trop loin pour la rue regretté est
d'ailleurs sur la question de la peur la
prochaine question je crois qu'elle est
un peu dans cette optique là comment
surmonter la peur d'être seule en plus
loin de chez soi en tant que femme
grande question alors la peur d'être
seule c'est pas la peur de se faire
agresser dessous l'année sur la peur
d'être seule la solitude en moi je
trouve que c'est un énorme avantage est
vrai souvent c'est quelque chose qui
fait peur moi j'avais peur par exemple
de manger tout seul au resto mais je te
jure vraiment oui je resserre un peu un
tube place à la cantine de l'école
famille tous les genres du coup quand je
suis parti au canada
jean la meuf par al sur un autre
continent tout seul et tout je prends
des buts de nîmes et lorsque j'avais pu
à sa phobie s'est pas formalisé nuit
c'est de manger tout seul
en plus j'avais jamais tout ce que
l'ipad sujet était une fois mais du coup
j'étais j'avais économisé pour pouvoir
aller au restaurant une fois et
mais du coup j'étais tellement en fait
j'avais un resto j'avais un peu du
confort aussi parce que je voyageais
vraiment à la route je suis un peu trop
si j'avais internet ou quoi mais pas de
portable donc j'étais assez la table
tout seul sans occupation
tu as un truc qui n'existe plus en
examen est vraiment j'étais à 100% dans
métro bonne frite l'avait alors si pas à
ça c'est quoi le truc qui te faisais fin
à ce qu'il y avait un élément un peu sur
la peur d'être seule non en fait le fait
d'être seul
on se rend compte qu'en fait il ya
toujours des solutions à tous moi c'est
vraiment un truc que je devais les
premières choses que j'ai appris en
brèche et et ça c'est qu'en fait il n'y
a pas de stress en fait les petits trucs
de la vie ils sont toujours réglable
enfin vraiment le sol très grave c'est
de mourir mais je sais tu as peut-être
coupé non mais en fait c'est vrai que ça
fait graver relativiser mais bien sûr en
fait moi pareil quand j'étais au liban
j'ai claqué la porte de mon appartement
et j'avais la clé à l'intérieur sur la
porte
vous voyez le délirant fait des trucs
trop long j'ai appelé un serrurier qui
m'a dit qu'il ne pouvait rien faire a et
donc ils ont dû appeler un ouvrier qui
assis et m'apporte par le bas qui a
passé la main pour récupérer la clé et
ensuite ils sont revenus ils ont démonté
va fort ils ont remis et tout ça pour
dire que ça je pouvais j'avais même pas
où dormir enfin norvège venait d'arriver
ah ouais tu venais d'arriver à sa
défense un jour deux tu vois ah ouais
c'est chaud c'est chou navet tu as la
différence entre les gens qui ont peur
d'être seul ou pas c'est tout moi
j'avais déjà voyagé toute seule et
j'étais avec ma cousine qui l avaient
pas encore vraiment voyager tout seul et
qui avait surtout voyagé un truc un peu
organisés à l'avant sur d'accord et on
est arrivé un robe longueur rome le sky
ne pense pas loin c'est pas différent et
ça me fout quoi bref on a l a vu en
cadeau en gros de nuit une nuit d'hôtel
à rome pour deux personnes et on avait
pris beaucoup l'hôtel les nous donc on
arrive on va jusqu'à la station de rer
indiqué eon captent qu'en face on est
loin dans la banlieue genre vraiment ça
commence à être vraiment loin et on sort
de là et on sourit aux audacieux de
parking avec eux des toxicos partout et
tout genre un peu flippant et rien genre
ss d'autoroute et tout est là je
commence à me
et il était bien minuit une ennemie elle
même un peu plus que ça emma vous ai
commencé à s'inquiéter
et dans ces moments là comme moi j'ai
déjà fin j'ai déjà franchi ce stade de
se débrouiller
ouais bah je vais moi je m'attendais à
voir les gens là soute et des temps tu
savais que retiendra-t-on mais ça suffit
la situation est comme elle est en fait
tu as exactement du coup tu avais peur
ou honte et pamela ware et du coup je
suis allé taper la discute avec le
gardien du parking hors jeu par l'état
italien donc bah je parlais pas italien
mais tu baralbine avait sur l'espagnol
enfin bref c'était pas terrible mais il
a compris qu'on était tout seul contre
valence en droit il a compris que
c'était loin c'était compliqué et
c'était la grève des taxis
ah oui à la yann qui cumule comme ça
mais ma cousine était quand même assez
inquiètes de l'ambiance et tout est au
final tu as notamment où tu fais
confiance aux mecs puisque tu dis mais
en fait lui ok je lui fais confiance
quoi tu te décides que exactement ouais
en fait est là enfin
du coup vous étiez n'était pas seul mais
tu étais presque cei parce que je vais
je là j'irai quoi tu nous regardes la
queen b tu vas adorer mai mais en fait
c'est vraiment ça c'est de mettre sa
confiance dans les autres sacs c'est
vrai et c'est dû lâcher prise de fouet
et du coup t'as pas peur d'être seule
à partir du moment où tu dis que tu vas
pouvoir faire confiance à des gens aussi
et tu as ce n'est qu'on lui a fait
confiance il nous a dit je finis mon
boulot d'un trois heures donc on a
poireauté trois heures dans une cabine
de parking par le football c'était
passionnant et en fait il nous a déposé
à l'hôtel avec sa voiture
donc il me carmen rioux a sauvé sa
tournée jamais seul en voyage ça qu'il
faut c'est exactement ce que tu vois
j'ai insulté mène plus seul quand tu
voyages avec quelqu'un ce n'est que
quand et où c'est parce que moins de
gens viennent te parler tu rends compte
moins de genre et ben toi tu es plus
ouverte elle a rencontré quand tu es
tout seul et surtout ce qui est trop
bien c'est que tu décides le moment où
tu as envie d'être avec des gens
exactement à ce moment que je sais tout
seul alors question suivante est ce que
vous êtes déjà senti en insécurité
honnêtement en fait quand je dis ça les
gens croient pas mais honnêtement toutes
les anecdotes de de peur que j'ai eues
en voyage c'était pas du tout les eaux
fait est une femme ah ouais non genre
moi ma plus grosse grosse part c'est un
encerclement
saint venant
non mais en général un horrible avec des
singes aussi mais j'ai moins peur mais
j'ai fait un essai avec des samples de
l'argent frais ni des autres j'adore les
singes genre genre gamme ans adore les
frais de mise au point en fait c'est
vrai que une fois j'ai eu peur d'un
singe mais sinon j'aime bien c'est vrai
que c'est assez impressionnant non mais
c'est vrai que en fait au final il n'y a
pas de tant de fois où pareil je me sens
descendant sécurisé il ya une fois où
j'ai vraiment flippé été au canada
donc tu vois comme quoi on pense qu'on
voyage dans des pays safe parce que
voilà
mais en fait au canada dans une auberge
de jeunesse où j'étais il ya un mec qui
était assez fâché de voir une
quarantaine d'années est clairement il a
commencé un peu à faire des afin d
avance à ce que sa saison soit en gros
il a essayé de m'enfermer dans la
chambre voilà quoi et en fait mais tu
vois c'est la première fois aussi où
j'ai crié c'est pour alerter des gens
parce que il ya aussi ce truc où on
était toujours associé de socialisation
par la peur et tout il ya quand même ce
truc de se taire de faire de bruit et
tout est là le moment où tu es tout seul
en fait c'est beaucoup plus consciente
du danger je trouve aussi bizarrement
non n'était pas exposé attendre danger
concerne cependant tu le comprends très
vite alors on a été baisser les stores
le paysage a changé mais reprenons nos
questions est-ce que vous avez regretté
à un moment d'être partis sans un mec à
vos côtés en mode
si c'était à refaire celle vous
refuserez cette pression est terrible
parce que c'est vraiment un truc que je
me suis jamais dit jean-noël l'ami non
le contraire on voit ça et c'est tout ce
que j'adore quand tu vois la différence
voyage seul ou quand tu voyages avec un
homme qui seront partenaires ont passé
qu'en fait tu disparais en fait les gens
c'est par louey qu'à lui pincer un crois
surtout quand on tue ouais j'en ai pays
qui sont plus conservateurs qui sont
qui sont conservateurs qui voient là où
il ya vraiment oui j'étais très sexiste
très patriarcale enfin tu disparais de
la surface glacée ça ils vont s'adresser
qu'à lyon c'est aurait limité les gens
qui ont refusé de parler ce même sillage
de côté aussi ou août à témoin deux fois
même c'est moins à l'aise tu tu rends
compte beaucoup moins de gens enfin
vraiment à tous les
toutes les rencontres incroyables que
j'ai fait en voyage s'étaient quand
j'étais seul en fait la présence d'un
homme sa touche en jetant voyage ça
change la perception que les gens ont de
toi oui en fait c'est ça en fait c'est
vrai problème que le mec soit là parce
que c'était un mec super sympa super
disponibles fin de mai c'est vrai tu as
mélo prennent c'est que ça reflète un
truc sur toi ça rebondit et jamal
compagne de quelqu'un ou lorsque souvent
même quand c'est ton ami en général
enfin des gens pensent directement en
conflit et donc du coup tu marques tu
viens la compagne de sept personnes dont
peut-être une existence un peu
négligeable c'est importe quoi c de 6 à
des voyageuses dans mes pays est un peu
conservateur et sookie m genre à une
alliance pour faire durer son mari ah
oui les faute d'alliance alors moi et
c'est personnel je comprends vraiment en
fait le raisonnement qui fait que tant
dans la salle on va dire que ça
simplifie la vie voilà un nom je pense
mais pour moi c'est vraiment mais là
c'est du presque du militantisme en fait
c'est que j'ai pris la décision de quand
je dois refuser les avances les avances
de quelqu'un d'un homme d'un taxi
souvent c'est ouais je veux pas qu'en
fait il pense que si je dis non c'est
juste parce que je suis déjà prises en
fait j'ai ouais c'est juste assez juste
de respecter veut pas accepter que je
veux pas tu m'as fait que si c'est parce
que ça va entaché l'honneur d'un autre
mec en gros c'est sa mère après moi
c'est un principe mais vraiment je
comprends alors il ya une question c'est
est-ce que la solitude vous a pesé
bah moi pas du tout mais genre jamais
jeu franchement non ouais mais en fait
non pas et bien peu avant mais l
avantage que quand tu es tout seul c'est
que c'est à vous d'être tout seul tu es
tout seul c'est un oubli de taille les
jambes en fait tu t'es grave décomplexé
au bout d'un moment tu veux avoir les
gens tu commences à part toi moi oui oui
nos agences commencent à barder
vous faites un truc ce soir en fait les
amitiés en voyage tu vois on pourrait
presque faire une vidéo jeux bac rue
savidan la chaîne offre les amitiés en
voyage c'est vraiment c'est encore un
monde à part les gens qui rend compte en
voyage même les gens que tu sais que tu
vas jamais moi je me souviens pas
c'était à jérusalem je me souviens ça
c'est la plus belle rencontre de wesh
que j'ai fait c'était un couple
il était incroyable et en fait c'était
des norvégiens il a fait le tour de tout
continent africain en moto mais il avait
eu des histoires du fou je pourrais même
pas tout raconter né et j'ai même pas
voulu prendre leurs numéros quoi c'était
juste j'avais envie de garder une
rencontre de voyage en famille avant
tout à l'avant typique j'avais patrice
aroui de l'avoir c'était vraiment ce
soir là c'était génial de parler avec
mes alors la question suivante alors
nous et mangue cinq petites tips
indispensables pour réussir son voyage
avec moi le premier ouais le premier
truc qui me vient comme ça c'est le truc
de il faut s'informer repéré savoir un
peu ce qu'on a envie de faire vraiment
d'essentiel peut savoir un peu les
incontournables autant envie de faire
mais ne pas tout organisé par ya
tellement de gens qui ont que tu as
croisé qui vont de proposer des choses
qui vont faire dévier la trajectoire que
tu avais forcément un tout image in et
1,3 que tu as fait un voyage en plus où
tu étais un peu en voie de ouais en fait
non c'est un moment dans ma vie où je
m'étais fixé la règle ce qui est un peu
une règle stupide vraiment mais je
m'étais fixé angola règle de ne jamais
dire non est en fait fins et c'est
absurde en fait parce que tu te mets
dans des situations je te retrouve avec
des gens d'un morcellement envie d'être
enfin voilà en or des recettes pour être
le deuxième type sain c'est carré voire
dire non ça alors dire audi annonce
avoir dit non parce qu'en fait tu as
besoin de monter responsable que de toi
mais deux personnages en fait si tu te
dis pas non et surtout dans ma situation
mais de galère et c'est juste pour être
poli au bout d'un moment à quel point tu
te mets en danger pour être polis parce
quand même un truc de fou c'est pas
forcément le truc de la politesse aussi
le côté philosophie en fait genre c'est
pas bien de dire non mais c'est en fait
c'est vrai qu'il faut savoir dire non et
c'est marrant parce que tu vois on va
voir l'image du voyage solo où tu te dis
il ya peut-être des gens qui me
regardent et qui se disent mais qu'est
ce que je vais faire un voyage rien à
faire une fois que j'ai fait toutes les
visites et en fait enfin après je pense
que ça dépend aussi des destinations
mais la plupart du temps en fait cette
dure de sa de dire non ces deux là se
trouvaient dans des plans on propose
toujours gentil mais en plus quand tu es
tout seul il ya peu que ce truc où c'est
plus pratique plus j'entends mener avec
toi ouais c'est une place dans la
voiture est un lit dans le dortoir tête
à tête de la 5e roddick un appel parce
que romain c'est hyper du sind est seul
ouais les gens du mal et je pense c'est
vraiment faim c'est même pas je pense
c'est très culturelle c'est le côté en
fait c'est dur d'expliquer aux gens tout
est parfait j'ai eu ça aussi on peut en
iran tueur à ses côtés non vraiment tout
est parfait vous êtes géniaux mais cela
en fait là maintenant j'ai envie d'être
tout le temps en inde je voyageais avec
une amie il y avait déjà ce truc un peu
de tout le temps vouloir être avec nous
mêmes des étrangers qui étaient voyager
en mai parce qu ils ont l'impression que
l'on vient trucs horribles et du coup ça
veut dire que le deuxième 6 escaut
savoir dire non voilà le premier type se
renseigner mais pas tout planifié en
faisant savoir dire non et je pense
aussi tu vois ce genre suivre son
instinct quoi c'est un peu ce qu'on
faisait la moue se faire confiance et
impôts s'était alors genre ouais faire
confiance à s'écouter se en face à
prioriser aussi tu as cas où celle ci
est en fait c'est banal mais c'est
vraiment écouté son car en fait
ensuite parce que quoi d'autre je dirai
aussi que c'est pas parce que tu es tout
seul que tu dois rester isolé clairement
et que nous faut pas avoir peur d'aller
vers les gens par exemple tu vois quand
j'étais au japon j'aime à toi quand tu y
tiens mais j'avais vachement de mal à à
me connecter avec les gens
moi ça a été loupé le plus difficile
pour ça mais au niveau linguistique déjà
bas mon niveau de japonais était de zéro
et puis en plus j'avais l'impression un
peu dérangée gens ou d'un schéma je le
sens pas dans une relation où je pouvais
être salué
et en fait j'ai continué à essayer et je
me suis retrouvé avec un coach surfeur
qui m'a qui m'a accueilli chez lui et tu
as qui m'a fait rencontrer d'autres gens
et souhaits en fait si je m'étais arrêté
à quelques échelle si tu t'arrêtes à ça
mais en fait on tenait lui
des belles rencontres parce qu'il faut
continuer d'essayer de s'ouvrir de
connecter un autre conseil qu'on peut
donner c'est de d'essayer d'apprendre
les éléments de langage de la langue
mais en tout cas j'ai les expressions
toutes faites des expressions de
politesse et vraiment ça aide a souvent
même même si on peut pas avoir une
conversation sa valise la glace a brisé
la glace à dédramatiser un truc chez
jean c'est sa grand chose mais ça donne
un côté humain tu as aussi cette
expérience de toi toi tu parles bien
turquie et genre t'es tu vois ce que je
veux dire c'est que ça change tout la
relation avec un pays de ses éclairs de
tout connaître le nom et de divinement
bien sûr c'est pas possible d'apprendre
la langue dans tous les pays mais juste
de s'intéresser en fait parce que ça
c'est un monde que tu as fait l'effort
et intérêts c'est un minimum et je pense
que ça touche les gens en fait de base
quand arrivait que et essaye même si
basse à abattre loin tu fini par parler
avec des gestes improbables et ses
appareils un manque en jeu en amérique
latine jalenques ferait un gars qui
voyagent et patrick un frisbee trop bien
ça lui permettait de créer des liens
genre mais si ça doit sans cesse il ya
tout en fait le frisbee dans son sexe et
genre il le sortait un peu tout le temps
puis frisbee c'est super ça prend pas de
place
là est en fête saluant le saumon les
enfants les jeunes les moins jeunes tu
peux inventer un modèle c'est vrai
d'avoir des petites connexions ses
parents non là c'est lé langage qui
n'est pas par la parole mais qui le et
d'étapes en quelques mots utilisés tous
les aspects du langage la danse le
summum le jeu la musique je vois
instrument c'est génial ça hors du coup
nos cinq types si on résume ne pas tout
organiser seul essai voilà pour
spécifier ce plancher plat et doivent se
faire confiance suivre son instinct
championnat instinct de parapheurs de
dire non non pas de dire non et d'aller
vers les gens ni d'aller vers les gens
et
après ça alors c'est quoi les meilleurs
aspects du voyage solo je pense le truc
le plus marrant je restais c'est un peu
bas toi mais la liberté n'ont cessé ces
mêmes que ça en fait enfin ses limites
vertigineux tellement tu est rattachée à
rien en fait new delhi enfin tous tes
choix ne dépendre que de ses envies de
ce que tu as ce moment là enfin c'est
une dépend que de toi tu dois quand même
si on expulse des gens peuvent t'aider
tu dépends quand même toi qui prends la
décision finale est annoncée d'être
libre et de fin vraiment surtout le fait
quand on commence jeune et qu'on grandit
un peu comme sa faconde matures comme ça
ça fait ouais ça fait vraiment grandir
ça fait vraiment changé c'est je pense
qu'on ne mesure pas à quel point enfin
si mais on a un prêt notre personnalité
entre et on serait pas le même sans ça
m'est impossible impossible ça donne une
autonomie une indépendance et une
confiance en chine inde chili là le
ceclr gens vraiment à prêter j'en ai
rien à [ __ ] un parent peut atteindre
mais ça t'enlève toutes les coutures est
ce que l'epr sont construites que en
fait égal de débrouiller tout seul ne va
pas besoin de quelqu'un à etoy mais
ouais non non ça vraiment sas et puis le
fait vraiment ça a une dimension encore
plus incroyable pour pour une femme en
fait ouais en fait c'est comme de
réussir à trouver son intégrité et en
même temps a tellement lâché prise que
tu vas me dire ce que c'est toi ça te
fait pareil mais moi ça va quand même
aidé à déconstruire plein de trucs qui
tu es c'est dans l'éducation féminine
prévu que sont des femmes est en fait
c'est ça moi j'ai l'impression d'avoir
genre évolué parallèlement genre ma vie
de voyages ma passion pour pour l'
aventure tout ça et doc c'est mon
intérêt pour le féminisme
il ya un moment donné ou en fait les
deux au fond c'est une collision
et là c'est l'incroyable sensation c'est
de vraiment d'arriver à relier les deux
le grand aventurier dans l'imaginaire
collectif
c'est le mec c'est le baroudeur viril
mal rasé
et en fait sur plein respect pour une
femme c'est encore plus une
transgression en fait de voyager disons
le mail et la vraie aventure incroyable
vraiment le changement de ville le le
grand coup de pied dans le dos la
société tous et c'est le voyage des
femmes et en plus de transgresser savane
te construire autrement par exemple j'ai
faim je bats toi t'as un truc vraiment
concret que tu as des construit grâce
aux voyages entame de l'éducation fait
mais c'est vraiment le la question de la
peur d'aborder construit cette
socialisation par la peur dit j'ai un
truc alors c'est vraiment d'exemple
précis doit dire premier voyage je
partis en sac à dos et je suis dit vas-y
c'est le moment ou jamais de toute façon
personne ne te connaît là-bas t'as rien
à prouver à personne et je suis parti
sans maquillage du tout du tout du tout
après c'est vrai que ça fait partie dans
libération c'est vrai que vivre le truc
de la libération jusqu'au bout ouais
c'est ça meiway du coup ça m'a apporté
ce truc de me détacher totalement du
regard des autres
dre que le voyage a permis de se
soustraire à face à la la j'ai commencé
à avoir un je m'en foutisme monumental
maquillage ça va c'est alors le chill et
tout ça mais je crois qu'on a plus de
question j'ai l'impression que faudra 10
25 ans même talent fou ce débat soulève
ouais ouais c'est bizarre mais on a
raconté mme à quelques unes de nos
adeptes des voyages un peu marrante et
non mais c'est pas que ça vous a plu
on essaie ça vous a plu en tout cas
mouais c'était ben voilà juste vraiment
notre expérience à toutes les deux voilà
mon expérience personnelle et notre
vision des choses qui peuvent vraiment
varié je pense je pense que tu dois y en
a dans toutes les meufs qui voyage et
tous ces éléments d'expériences
différentes voilà et plein de
problématiques que nous on n'a pas
rencontré que d'autres peuvent avoir
rencontré le but de cette vidéo c'était
vous montrer un peu déjà les obstacles
au voyage au féminin et que en fait ça
vaut carrément le coup a carrément de
tenter l'expérience et ses faux pas faux
pas ne pas le faire parce qu'on a peur
parce qu'on a peur parce que on entendre
pour une femme c'est compliqué là
évidemment on est tous un peu confiné
car je vois comment vous c'est chez vous
mais non
on est confiné donc on espère aussi que
cette vidéo à vous aura un peu fait
voyager les mots ouais et on espère que
les voyages pour moi et il est jamais
trop tard encore pour reprendre avec
sandra d'avinel elle a renouvelé son
passeport à 101 ans et elle est morte
juste après mais elle pensait continuer
et donc qui vous soyez partez
ouvrez-vous et d'ailleurs on peut
voyager en france ainsi jamais vide se
cale dans tous les cas on est soit cette
vidéo vous aura intéressé que serveuse
aura en tout cas on s'est bien marré à
la ferme et suivez la chaîne sont sur le
coup allez surtout suivre aussi sur
twitter pourrait rater de la sortie de
son livre
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo vous allez
adorer nolly domicile armand je mettrai
le twitter et elle installe de lucien
barre d'infos pour ceux qui sont
intéressés c'est comme ça qu'on fait sur
youtube et suivent a cité un plaisir de
mastic team honda avec vous
et tu as à très bientôt sur ces logos à
bientôt
[Musique]